on se retrouve du coup avec un nom
d'artiste qui n'ont pas forcément chez
sur un sujet identique mais finalement à
créer un ensemble vraiment remis
accrochage mise en scène cadrage à
l'association hélium on est artiste
maison met aussi la main à la pâte pour
installer une exposition nous sommes
soixante huit artistes à participer à
cette exposition collective c'est un
vrai challenge lorsque ça fait beaucoup
beaucoup d'oeuvres beaucoup de l'univers
beaucoup de directions de travail à
mettre les uns à côté des autres mais ça
donne une vitrine une vraie un vrai
panorama sur sur ce qu'est il ya mais
ces artistes
68 exposants à l'espace la chapelle de
clairefontaine pour une exposition grand
angle qui regroupe peintures sculptures
photographies mais aussi des oeuvres
plus singulières fait de terre et de
pierres ce tableau que je présente en
fait ils s'appellent topographe ya
l'histoire que voilà j'ai essayé de
raconter c'est que dans un futur qui va
être malheureusement assez proches ont
c'était d'imaginer que des gens vont
faire des fouilles archéologiques la
terre aura repris ses droits et que
quand on va creuser en fait dans le sol
on va retrouver les constructions
d'aujourd'hui à l'extérieur de
l'enceinte un artiste travaille à
l'écart afin de mettre en valeur la
nature je réalise des grandes peintures
que j'appelle du bambou land art parce
que ce sont des grandes peintures tendue
sur des bambous arc et il me reste aussi
à attendre le vent parce que ce qui est
intéressant c'est quand le soleil bien
sûr joue sur les couleurs et que le vent
soulève l'étoile l'effet ondulé alors là
c'est absolument magnifique
l'exposition grand-angle sera en accès
libre dès ce samedi 5 mars pour les
trois premiers week-ends du mois